lots of good conspiracy theories involve
so-called shadow governments a shadow
government according to the conspiracies
is more or less the idea that the
official government we know about the
one where you know there's a president
and a Senate and a House of
Representatives and a Supreme Court all
of that stuff that they don't actually
wield the power okay a shadow government
conspiracy theory claims that the real
official government are puppets but that
the actual power is held by private
individuals or corporations depending on
the conspiracy theory sometimes it's
organizations like the Bilderberg
conspiracies are factions of this the
Jews sometimes the Vatican the
Freemasons many flavors of this one and
the deep state is another one which has
been sort of popular during the Trump
administration it's not actually the
government as we see it publicly that
holds the power it's this deep state
entity that is actually wielding the
power and holding the purse strings and
the puppet masters of what our
government officials do of course
there's always like a shadow of truth to
these conspiracy theories that's how
people get pulled in so with this one
it's well okay yeah there are elites and
corporations that do have way more power
disproportionately compared to Joe Schmo
lower middle class guy that that's true
and that's what gets people sucked into
this stuff and then they go down the
rabbit hole of the really belligerent
and outrageous ideas so that's all a set
up to tell you that Donald Trump's son
Eric Trump not known to be the most
intelligent one he suggested on Twitter
that liberal comedian Ellen DeGeneres is
part of such a deep state conspiracy
shadow government and the tweet is so
insane that he eventually deleted it but
we have the text of it to show you Eric
trump tweeting on January 3rd shocking
once again here are the Twitter
suggestions of who I should follow
hashtag deep state and then he links to
a picture which showed that Twitter's
algorithm was suggesting to him
that he follow Hillary Clinton Barack
Obama and Ellen DeGeneres on Twitter
quite a conspiracy the deep state has
cooked up the deep state this
all-powerful shadow government is trying
to manipulate people up to and including
the son of the President of the United
States by suggesting that he follow
Ellen DeGeneres on Twitter as well as a
former president and someone who lost
the presidential election more than two
years ago at this point the thing about
this one cot is that it's so stupid and
so dumb and he was so roasted for it
that even he ended up deleting the tweet
to try to take attention off of it
because it is quite frankly absolute
idiocy yeah not not the brightest bulb
on the tree that's for sure but at least
Eric Trump is an inspiration to some of
us even if you're not the smartest even
if you're not the hardest-working you
can still become rich and successful as
long as your grandparent starts some
successful real estate company and you
live off of his successes yeah I I I
don't know if that's an inspirational
tale or a depressing tale that you can
you we are reminded by Eric Trump and
Ivanka and Don as well but in particular
with Eric you don't have to be smart you
don't have to be a good person you don't
have to be likable you don't have to be
reasonable you don't have to have a
sensible head on your shoulders to end
up with a ton of money in the United
States but we actually already knew that
so it's either a tale of inspiration or
something that should make us all very
very depressed but to get back to the
shadow government that Eric Trump
alluded to I would probably trade in the
Trump government with a Republican
Senate for one run by Barack Obama
Hillary Clinton and Ellen DeGeneres like
is it crazy to think that we would be
better off with Clinton Obama and Ellen
running the government than what we
actually have that actually seems
favorable if you throw in Oprah Winfrey
and like Steve Harvey I think I may be
convinced in that point I read a funny
comment online that Eric Trump is just
jealous that Ellen DeGeneres is able to
date more attractive women that he's
able to date but that's an insult to
Eric's wife if he's still married I
don't know if he's divorced also so I
won't make that
myself I'll just quote someone else who
made it on the Internet